blow the reject nation Greg Alba here
and I'm John Humphrey we were gonna
watch today the trailer for a pokémon's
detective Pikachu official trailer
numero uno I'm actually really excited
for this John and I became best friends
in third grade all because we bonded
over Pokemon isn't that an exciting
story and you can bet we've kept up to
date
ever since then we're gonna go do this
before we do that I wanted to say thank
you thank you thank you to everyone who
was following us on our patreon over
there we do TV show reactions for many
of shows that includes anime like attack
on Titan Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood my hero academia and also we
do live-action shows like Supernatural
Riverdale and Gotham John also does
music video coverage this voice is kind
of annoying let's get to it shall we
whoa they did it yeah
[Music]
okay watching my business
[Music]
[Laughter]
we're gonna do this in me oh yeah Wow
listen up
[Music]
dude this is like fun man oh it's the
one thing I was wondering is are we
going to have to confront the harsh
reality of actual Pokemon fight it
really from deep eat DP that's what he's
done right oh wow
part of me couldn't even really have
taken the storyline at first and like is
this even if you could move it was just
like I completely forgot this was
live-action I thought this is animated
yeah I'm gonna see the live-action like
oh my god they've they brought Pokemon
the life I feel like waiting for this
forever even though I haven't been
following the shows and anything in so
long I've been waiting for a live-action
Pokemon movie to work
I mean Pokemon has been part of our
lives for so long and it's brought so
many of us together from our day yeah oh
and we had the games we had the movies
we had the show and all that and yeah
it's like I haven't even kept up with
Pokemon go or anything but I felt like a
child
yeah like seeing the world realized
fully is it's almost weird because there
have been a bunch of animated Pokemon
movies and now to see it in live-action
I got it
I feel like Rob Letterman is becoming
the guy we're going to for you know
let's take a world that has like a lot
of CG but they're also kind of cartoony
creatures and incorporate them yeah
there's a lot of what goosebumps was
like too so uh but yeah this looks like
a lot of fun oh this looks like a blast
dude I can't wait to watch this movie
just for that nostalgia factor alone and
the fact that they honed in I'm
primarily Pokemon that you know even
people like us from what first became
popular to really show that brought to
life like Charizard and Bulbasaur to be
like yeah these are the familiar ones
you know yeah it's taking it back a
little bit by how the cinematography was
rather tired when I was watching it oh
they have this kind of like dark looking
film and even though this trailer is
very upbeat in its Pokemon there's gonna
be a lot of goofiness and riot rattling
and be you know the the inner voice of
Pikachu yeah I imagine like there's
gonna be some dark elements to this
because if you're looking at the trailer
it's good it's really kind of got this
dark cinematography but I don't know if
it did that just for the visual effects
that way it looks more realistic because
that's usually what helps with VFX and
at the same time though I've always
thought Pokemon kind of lends itself to
a dark story if you really think about
it
it's it's these humans who are kind of
abusive he's animal you know they can
fight each other for their own
entertainment trapping them in balls and
being like now my own amusement fight
each other you know yeah so I feel like
it does lend itself to something I could
go on the darker side as far as this
storyline goes I'm not I think detective
Pikachu is an actual thing yeah that
game and you you know go around and
solve little mysteries yeah nothing here
they're looking for his dad man and as
much as I love the Ryan Reynolds voice
you know I feel like this yeah I will be
thinking of Ryan Reynolds every time
he's talking I won't be like lost in
Pikachu yeah and with that sort of
sarcastic attitude I wonder how much I'm
going to be reminded of Deadpool well
watch I mean Ryan Reynolds is already
Deadpool but with that extra slice of
attitude yeah I mean that definitely
brings them close together in my mind oh
absolutely and when he was talking like
oh it's Deadpool but that yeah but that
would you know had that brief oh oh yeah
yeah that part really got to me cuz oh
yeah you'll get both sides it'll warm up
your heart string cuz I can't tell if
this is gonna be an actual good movie I
don't like looking back on whatever
either way it's a fun it looks like a
fun entertaining family film and I'm
sure there's gonna be laughs to be had
is this gonna be great I don't know
it'll probably be fun yeah we're Joya
below Garlits that's all I really want
from this is just a fun enjoyable film
that only I don't need something
groundbreaking I want the Pokemon to
feel like they've been brought to life
and to have a human character like this
like I imagine will be in their shoes
and everything yeah and I can actually
even though I was thinking of the Ryan
Reynolds voice being too Deadpool
familiar I think that's a smart choice I
don't know if that's how it is in the
detective Pikachu game I think that's a
smart choice because you can't just
watch a movie the whole time with like
you know a group like character yeah
it's funny in the game is he's kind of
reminded me of the jump between like the
original penny wise in the old penny
wise cuz the game voice is a little more
like yeah but I really I feel like this
could wind up being like a perfectly
enjoyable kind of heartwarming family I
feel like this could hit that goose bone
Calibur itch yeah partly because - I
mean you have Rob Letterman on the
direction you got Nicole Pearlman who
wrote the original draft of guardians of
the galaxy see you bet that this will be
kind of a punchy you know witty script a
stuff like that everything it man really
and I really like Justice Smith actually
like I from what I've seen of the
get-down I really liked him in that and
he was one of the things I did like
about Dresden fallen Kingdom and I'm
excited to see him lead this you know I
like him a lot plus Ken Watanabe showing
how much would be jeopardy lend some
credit for that dude yeah man and this
trailer was really art doing is teasing
character and tone and world and
everything but I think one thing we're
gonna get that's not really shown in
this trailer but I'm sure they're gonna
deliver on so that one shot from
Charizard they're probably gonna get
some really bomb action moments where
like they brought them don't look like
it's one thing to just see them an
imagery but I think that chars our
moment got me so exciting like we're
probably gonna get some really cool
Pokemon action to ultimately this is
gonna be a mashup movie of all the
Pokemon video games so it'll be like
pokemon stadium for a little bit then
it'll be pokemon snap and their montage
brews taking pictures of stuff yeah
actually that that scene though where
he's standing against the gate you know
clearly it's some kind of big matchup
that almost reminded me of something
like real steel or something like that I
wonder how much that element is gonna
play in and how they're gonna handle
that just because this will be the first
time we crossover into a real world the
argument about Pokemon and animal
cruelty usually gets held up in that
well it's a fantasy and it's a cartoon
but now that it's no longer cartoon I'm
curious as to how that's gonna come
across I guess what do you guys think
are you excited for detective Pikachu is
Ryan Reynolds's voice distracting for
you or does it work should you've played
me out leave a comment down below guys I
want to wrap this video up by giving a
page from the day shout-out to a man
named JT our man from Hawaii
look JT we talk a lot we talk on Twitter
quite often you've been a longtime
patron followers of ours but let's face
it the reason I'm shouting out for this
you're the only Japanese man that we
have on our patreon so who better else
to shoutout then the one guy whose act
chillie japanese this must make you
really proud I'm so happy for you buddy
good job you earned it you are this guy
here except you're not black you are
Japanese I don't think I've pointed this
out enough but you being Japanese is the
reason we are shouting JT out in this
detective Pikachu video yeah man so hop
on your laparis right up and down the
hawaiian coast and get us some rare
candy why don't you yeah seven samurai
is a great movie Japan Godzilla
technology JT JT guys you can subscribe
to the reject nation click that
notification balichek a sign up patreon
TV show reactions q and A's and music
video coverage we'd love to have you
become patron Jick today